den
Es la primera vez que un expresidente
estadounidense se enfrenta a cargos
criminales
Donald Trump comparecerá ante un juez la
próxima semana para ser procesado en un
tribunal de Nueva York El Magnate
enfrenta múltiples cargos de
falsificación de registros comerciales
durante su campaña de 2016 debido a la
forma en la que su organización registró
un reembolso hecho a su abogado Michael
cohen Que pagó a una actriz porno para
que ocultara una relación extramarital
que sostuvieron
creo que tiene que asumir la
responsabilidad de todo lo que ha hecho
es un problema de toda la vida siempre
ha hecho lo que no debía si hubiera sido
cualquier otro ciudadano estadounidense
habría estado en la cárcel hace mucho
tiempo
pero para muchos de sus seguidores los
cargos judiciales contra Trump no son
serios o no son tan importantes e
incluso re el incondicional apoyó que le
consagran Donald Trump recaudó más de 4
millones de dólares para su campaña
electoral de 2024 en las horas que
siguieron el anuncio de su imputación
[Música]
y creo que ellos los demócratas y el
sistema judicial lo están haciendo mal
no creo que quiero decir podría pasarme
a mí podría pasarte a ti podría pasarle
a cualquiera Y creo que da un poco de
miedo y la gente tiene que despertar y
ver esto en realidad creo que le está
ayudando creo que ahora va a conseguir
más votos porque la gente quizás se
despierta y le vote Eso espero
la seguridad fue reforzada en las
afueras de la corte de Manhattan pero
también alrededor del capítulo donde las
autoridades temen que un evento similar
al ataque del 6 de enero de 2021 tenga
lugar cuando alentados por él sus
seguidores irrumpieron en la sede del
congreso para rechazar el resultado de
las elecciones en las que perdió frente
a Joe